Let's say that today-- and
we'll call today Day 1--
Day 1 is a Monday.
What I want to
figure out is what
is the Day 300 going to be?
What day of the week
will Day 300 be?
And I encourage you
to pause the video
and think about
that a little bit.
So let's just write out
the days of the week.
You have Monday-- I'll do this
in a different color-- you have
Monday, Tuesday, Wednesday,
Thursday, Friday, Saturday
and Sunday.
So if we had a
lower number here,
we could just fill this out.
Monday is Day 1.
Tuesday's Day 2.
Wednesday, Day 3.
4, 5, 6, 7.
I'll keep going.
Day 8, well, that's going
to be a Monday again.
9 10.
I'm almost writing
a calendar out.
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16.
So this is kind of useful.
I could just write
it out if I wanted
to figure out something
Day 16 or Day 20.
I could just write that out.
But this isn't that helpful if
I want to figure out Day 300
or especially
wouldn't be helpful
if I wanted to
figure out Day 3,000.
So can I come up with
some mathematical way
of thinking about what
Day 300 is going to be?
Well, as you see when I
started drawing this grid here,
this grid has rows.
And each row, you
have seven days in it.
And that makes sense.
There are seven
days of the week.
So is there a way that if
someone just gave you 16
without drawing
this grid, then you
would know that 16 is a Tuesday?
Well, one way to think about
it that might jump out at you
is you could divide 16 by 7.
That will tell you how many of
these rows will come before 16.
So 16 divided by 7 is 2.
You have 2 rows before
16 right over here.
You could get 7 into 16 2 times.
And then you have a remainder.
What is the remainder
when you divide 16 by 7?
16 divided by 7
is going to be 2.
2 times 7 is 14.
You're going to have
a remainder of 2.
So when we divide,
we've historically
cared more about this 2.
We normally care
more about well,
how many times
does it go into it.
But now, the remainder
is actually interesting.
The remainder is really
interesting here.
Because the remainder
tells you-- the first two
just tells you 7
goes into 16 2 times.
That's how many rows you have
before getting to the 16.
But then the remainder tells
you in that row where is the 16?
So the 16 is remainder 2.
So the 16 is not the first.
It's the second entry
in the third row.
And so it's going
to be a Tuesday.
Tuesday is the second day.
I know what you're saying.
Does that always work?
Well, let's try it out
with some other examples.
Let's imagine Day 25.
So let's just divide 25 by 7.
So I'll do it right
over-- I could do it.
I'm going to make sure
I have enough space.
So if I have 7 goes into
25, it goes 3 times.
3 times 7 is 21.
You have a remainder of 4.
So let's see.
So based on that-- so let
me rewrite this-- so 25
divided by 7 is equal
to 3, remainder 4.
So based on this, if we
were to write out the grid,
we should have three rows of
7 before we get to the 25.
And then 25 should sit
in the fourth column.
So if it's sitting
in the fourth column,
it should be a Thursday.
So Day 25, based on this
little math we just did,
should be a Thursday.
Let's see if that
actually works out.
So let's go to 17, 18, 19,
20, 21, 22, 23, 24 and 25.
It is indeed a Thursday.
But it makes complete sense.
You could get seven rows in it
before the row that gets to 25.
And then in that row, it's
going to be the fourth entry,
because you have
a remainder of 4.
1, 2, 3, 4.
It's going to be a Thursday.
So now we're ready to
answer the question.
What is Day 300 going to be?
So let's just divide 300
by 7 and see where we get.
7 goes into 30 4 times.
4 times 7 is 28.
Subtract, you get 2.
Bring down a 0.
7 goes into 20 2 times.
2 times 7 is 14.
And then we get our remainder.
And now we care much
more about the remainder.
20 minus 14 is 6.
So our remainder is 6.
So if we think about what day
of the week it is, in its row
it's going to be
the sixth entry.
It's going to be
the sixth column.
There's going to be
42 rows above it.
But we care about which
entry it is in its row.
So Day 300 is going to be
the sixth day of the week,
the way we've written it out.
It is going to be a Saturday.